un religieux convaincu verra partout la
marque de la présence de Dieu il vous
dira dieu est partout un militant
politique vous ira tout est politique un
religieux voudra convertir les gens
autour de lui un militant politique
voudra convaincre les gens autour de lui
un religieux pense que si tout le monde
partage ses croyances le monde sera
sauvé un militant pense que si tout le
monde partage ses opinions la société
sera sauvée un religieux va se référer à
un dogme à son texte religieux le
militant va se référer à un dogme sa
doctrine politique donc dans les deux
cas il y a besoin de se référer à un
dogme pour savoir ce qu'il faut penser
et dans la religion comme dans le
militantisme politique il y a besoin de
désigner le mal dans la religion le mal
c'est le diable et chez les militants
politiques le mal c'est soit le fascisme
soit le communisme et dans la religion
comme dans le militantisme politique on
nie la réalité quand la réalité
contredit notre pensée